diese studie stellt unser bisheriges
verständnis über extrasolare planeten
gehörig auf den kopf ein neues modell
eines forschungsteams legt jetzt nämlich
nahe dass es in fernen sternen systemen
deutlich mehr wasser planeten geben
könnte als erdähnliche gesteinsplaneten
und nicht nur das die ozeane dieser
knapp neptun großen exoplaneten könnten
tausende kilometer tief sein und damit
deutlich tiefer als die ozeane der erde
was genau hat es also mit diesen
gigantischen wasserwelten aufsicht krieg
zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
was die grundlage des lebens jahr ist
klar die erde wird nicht umsonst als
blauer planet bezeichnet flüssiges
wasser ist im sonnensystem allerdings
mangelware auch wenn beispielsweise auf
einigen monaten wie dem saturnmond
enceladus lupp glazialen also unter eis
liegende ozeane aufgespürt werden
konnten eine ganz andere sache ist das
aber wenn man auf extrasolare planeten
schaut die forschung ist diesbezüglich
noch nicht sehr weit und vieles ist
reine spekulation doch eine neue studie
der harvard university offenbart jetzt
eine überraschende erkenntnis demnach
gibt es wohl ein gigantischer
wasserwelten im all und das nicht zu
knapp die rede ist von sogenannten sub
neptun die in unserem sonnensystem nicht
vorkommen dafür aber in anderen fernen
sternen system masse mäßig stehen sie
eine stufe über den sogenannten
supererden sie weisen einen zwei- bis
vierfache im radius der erde auf und
sind damit wie gesagt größer als super
erden aber kleiner als der neptun
sie weisen ganz besondere
charakteristika auf denn ihre dichte ist
zwar höher als die rheiner gasriesen
aber meistens deutlich kleiner als die
dichte von gesteinsplaneten spekuliert
wurde bislang ob es sich vielleicht um
exoplaneten mit fels kernen und einer
gigantischen wasserstoff helium
atmosphäre handeln könnte oder sind so
bleibt ohne etwa kleine gas zwerge doch
das modell aus harvard legt jetzt nach
das ist etwas ganz anderes handeln
könnte nämlich um riesige wasserwelten
die möglicherweise sogar die
tausendfache wassermenge der erde
enthält
dazu zwängen der an der studie beteiligt
war planeten mit dem zwei- bis vierfache
radius der erde und etwa der zehnfache
masse sind wahrscheinlich wasserwelten
die fachleute hatten
computersimulationen zu durchmesser
masse und dichte von sub neptun
durchgeführt und das ergebnis ist auch
für die experten und expertinnen mehr
als überraschend die wasserwelten
könnten demnach zum großteil sogar aus
mehr als 50 prozent flüssigem oder
gefrorenem wasser bestehen auch bei dem
wasserdampf planet gj12 14b und dem
planeten um den roten zwerg glies 436
handelt es sich wohl um neptun große
welten die vielleicht sogar komplett von
einem ozean bedeckt sind und auch die
tiefen der ozeane könnte laut der neuen
berechnung enorm sein bis tausende
kilometer tief und somit fast zum kern
des planeten reichen dann wäre die
wasseroberfläche zwar flüssig in der
tiefe allerdings würde sich das wasser
durch den gewaltigen druck in exotische
eis formen verwandeln die fachleute
beschreiben das in ihrer studie als heiz
und hart und somit in gewisser weise
vergleichbar mit dem silikat gestein im
tiefen erdmantel das wasser dort könnte
laut dem neuen modell sogar bis zu 50
prozent der jeweiligen planeten masse
ausmachen so war gleich die wassermasse
unseres blauen planeten macht gerade
einmal 0,02 5 prozent der erdmasse aus
auch wenn die mehrere drei viertel der
oberfläche bedecken auch die daten des
kepler satelliten wurden in die studie
miteinbezogen
die auswertung der usb experten und
expertinnen legt nahe dass solche
gigantischen wasserwelten in der
gesamten galaxis sogar sehr häufig
vorkommen auch wenn sie in unserem
sonnensystem nicht existieren sind sie
im gesamten kosmos dagegen vielleicht
sogar häufiger vertreten als erdähnliche
felsplaneten dazu heißt es in der studie
rund 35 prozent aller bekannten
exoplaneten die größer sind als die erde
könnten wasserreich sein vielleicht hat
sogar jeder sonnenähnlichen stern einen
oder mehrere solcher wasser planeten
super spannende ergebnis also die aber
noch weiter bestätigt werden müssen
hochauflösende spektroskopie wie die des
james webb weltraumteleskop der nasa
könnten dabei in naher zukunft helfen
die chance ist groß dass fachleute somit
mehr
über die zusammensetzung der exoplaneten
atmosphäre fahren und dann auch dem
mysteriösen rätsel um die potenziellen
wasserwelten auf die spur kommen könnte
es planeten wie kurs angeben also an
planet wie man star wars der von einer
einzigen stadt bedeckt ist eine comen
o'polo comics tv widmet sich diesem
thema also hier anklicken anschauen und
unbedingt hast du kommst tv abonnieren
team fehlen noch 105 abos bis zu den
10.000 ich habe gewettet dass erst heute
schafft also bitte unterstützt mich dann
gewinne ich das zeigen wir euch dann in
unserem zwölf stunden live stream was
ich da gewonnen habe zur mondlandung am
20 juli bis dann bleibt dran